[Musik]
wie es unbekannten amerika präsentiert
das wissen wo es noch ein flug ausfällt
[Musik]
wenn ihr einmal weißen stein findet hebt
ihn nicht darf oder nimmt ihn mit nach
hause darin könnte ein geist wohnende
euch dann plan
mein name ist arthur honegger
acht jahre lang waren die usa mein
zuhause als korrespondent bin ich in
dieser zeit ganz schön rumgekommen 47
von 50 bundesstaaten habe ich besucht
und auch heute noch beschäftigt mich
dieses große verrückte land praktisch
nonstop bei meiner fernseharbeit
in dieser serie will ich nun ein
unbekanntes amerika entdecken
abseits der großen politik neue staaten
neue menschen neue erfahrungen
[Musik]
die badlands schlechtes land hat ein
häuptling es genannt als sein volk
hierher verschleppt wurde
interessant ein recht schlecht
vielleicht aber auch spektakulär er ein
paar tagen reiht sich hier durch wenn
ich das mit dem reiten überhaupt
hinbekommen
ich will vom stamm der lakota wärmen
nicht nur das reiten übers leben
generell ein vergessen das volk das
seine eigene kultur jedoch nie vergessen
hat
mensch tier natur alles ein großes
ganzes hier die weisheiten dahinter die
will ich entdecken
wer ist dieser kerl
das ist sicher es wird unangenehm mit
dir ein gutes gespräch zu führen mit
diesem ding vor deinem kopf nimmt die
kamera sogar mit ins bett auf dem pferd
mit diesem ding das wird bestimmt lustig
anzuschauen noch mal abwarten wer sich
auf dem pferd am lächerlichsten macht
wir sind alle anfänger sie können es
nicht erwarten euch auf den viel zu
sehen
willkommen in den usa in south dakota
und im pine ridge reservat im reservat
gibt es faszinierende menschen
doch sie neigen dazu schüchtern zu sein
kulturell bedingt wird sie nervös bei
einer kamera einige misstrauen nicht
ureinwohnern sehen wir werden erklären
was wir machen
woher wir kommen und was unser ziel ist
nämlich andere menschen deren kultur
besser zu verstehen
meine kinder sind viel bessere kinder
aufgrund dessen was sie von den menschen
hier im reservat gelernt kulturell wegen
der armut des fehlens von egoismus und
wegen der großzügigkeit
interessant fährt man nicht einfach so
rein der ventimiglia wird uns helfen in
diesem mikrokosmos zurechtzukommen
dave kennt sich hier aus sein hilfswerk
die pacers führt unter anderem wright
expeditionen durch
so sollen die kulturen einander näher
kommen und das hier ist unser zweiter
dave mein regisseur kameramann zerrte
und ich tauchen nun ein in eine uns
unbekannte welt wir sind in south dakota
und eine stunde von rapid city entfernt
im reservat pine ridge auf einer fläche
etwa ein viertel so groß wie die schweiz
leben hier rund 30.000 menschen vom
stamm der sioux sie selber nennen sich
lakota bevor wir das reservat genauer
erkunden können steht jetzt aber erstmal
die erste reitstunde meines lebens an
okay die pferde gehören hank bringing
back und seinen söhnen recht eng halten
nur mit den fingerspitzen
ich hatte große schuhe
du musst sie auf beiden seiten fest
du ziehst sie zurück dafür wirst du
ziehst an den zügeln und tritt zugleich
zeit
es ist als ob du die bremse drückt und
gleichzeitig das gaspedal
du willst du nicht bewegen würdest du
dich auf ihren rücken schwingen und
zeigen wie man sie bewegt sieht
eigentlich ganz easy aus zum start kurz
treten zügel rechts ziehen wir rechts zu
gelingen schien für links aber noch
fehlt mir das gefühl fürs tier kommt so
einiges mehr
es macht wirklich diese reitstiefel
anziehen ich denke da an habe ich mehr
platz
wir haben welche drinnen du kannst du
gerne holen sie ist brandneu
ich kann dir jedoch sagen es liegt nicht
daran schuld hat sich daheim eben schon
vorbereitet damit er angeben kann wird
jeder irgendwann passiert ich rede jetzt
seit 20 jahren
ich bin schon ziemlich oft auf dem boden
gelandet du hast fünf angefangen zu
reiten
wahrscheinlich noch früher denkt dran
seine tritte waren kurz und präzise
er halte sie in bewegung
[Musik]
du machst jetzt etwas anderes und darauf
reagiert sie du bewegst dich der sterne
oder
[Musik]
keine schwierigeres tempo zu halten mich
aber was war in ordnung
ich denke es ist gut gelaufen du wirst
es gut gemacht fürs erste mal
[Musik]
es macht spaß aber man muss wirklich
eine art verbindung zum pferd herstellen
das ist schwierig wenn man das nicht
gewohnt ist
ich bin sonst nicht oft von tieren
umgeben ich hatte mal eine katze aber
das war es dann auch wenn du die
verbindung zum pferd erst mal
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen erkunden wir das
reservat zur richtig
[Musik]
zentrum ist die stadt pine ridge mit
etwa 3000 einwohnern von ein paar
kleineren orten abgesehen leben die
menschen hier sonst weit verstreut auf
dem land
[Musik]
mitten im nirgendwo finden wir dann auch
den trailer von everett und charity day
bringt ihnen heute lebensmittel und
einen rasenmäher vorbei kommt everett
soll uns bald auf bison jagd begleiten
wie geht's nicht halten
seht ihr die ganzen rasenmäher mit denen
ich gearbeitet habe die haben sie aber
benutzt wie viele sind dass ich lebe auf
25 hektar da braucht man viele rasen und
ich habe gehört es gibt schlangen hin
klappe schlagen
ja meine frau ist wir reden hier seit
einmal kam ein doktor aus massachusetts
er wollte uns helfen und gab einer frau
geld er gab ihr 8000 um für uns in rapid
city einen anständigen wohnwagen zu
kaufen
aber sie tat das nicht
sie und ihr mann behielten das geld für
sich und brachten uns diesen
heruntergekommenen waren die holzböden
werden holen und einige sind
eingebrochen
also mussten wir bretter drauflegen die
decke und einen wasserschaden und die
wände sind wissen und was passiert wenn
es regnet
es ist schwierig hilfe von der
staatsführung zu erhalten
sie beachten uns nicht diese hoffnung
haben wir aufgegeben
es tut mir leid dass zu wahren gestern
haben sie uns den strom abgeschaltet
weil wir die rechten nicht sagen können
wir haben niemanden hier das immer so
hart für sie erwartet versucht uns dabei
zu helfen eine erlaubnis für die bison
jagte zu bekommen und ich gehe jetzt los
um das zu versuchen
danach kommen wir wieder zurück das ist
salbei wir zählen hier die wahrheit
deshalb haben wir den saal bei angezeigt
wir beten mit dem fallbeil auf um das
böse zu vertreiben
ich fühle hier sehr viel freundlichkeit
nichts böses
unser haus ist wir sind gleich zurück
ihr könnt auch gerne noch ein bild vom
badezimmer machen
das paar lebt hier zusammen mit enkel
fern der vater und mutter interessieren
sich kaum für den kleinen es fehlt an
allem einem anständigen trailer geld für
strom oder für die heizung die drei
bekommen zwar lebensmittelmarken doch
die sind oft mit dem monat schon
aufgebraucht
wer hier weit weg vom zentrum wohnt hat
pech die stammesführer so hören wir sind
vor allem um ihr eigenes wohl und das
ihrer nächsten besorgt
[Musik]
das ist die linke
naja da oben was bedeutet er ihnen warum
haben sie das bild aufgehängt
sitting bulls mit uns verwandt wirklich
ihr seid mit häuptling sitting bull
verwandt ist ein großes erbe ich hoffe
auch dass er euch kraft geben kann in
dieser harten zeit
die lizenz für die bison jagd haben wir
bekommen unsere stimmung ist trotzdem
gedrückt ich habe ja schon viel armut
gesehen in den usa aber das reservat ist
wie ein anderes land
jobs gibt kaum das haushaltseinkommen
ist halb so groß wie sonst im land kaum
eine familie die nicht mit alkohol oder
drogen problemen kämpft die
lebenserwartung liegt unter 67 jahren
ein tiefstwert in den usa
[Musik]
die geschichte dieses ortes spiegelt die
geschichte amerikas
bei seiner ankunft 1492 denkt columbus
offenbar er sei in indien und nennt die
menschen darum indianer
als die usa 1776 gegründet werden sind
schon über zwei millionen europäische
siedler im land
im namen der zivilisation wollen sie den
kontinent erobern
es folgen kriege massaker und gebrochene
versprechen gegenüber den ureinwohnern
[Musik]
hunderte von verträgen werden zwar
abgeschlossen doch nie eingehalten
[Musik]
zur gewalt kommen krankheiten die von
den weißen eingeschleppt werden die
urvölker sind diesen völlig ausgeliefert
weil ihnen die antikörper fehlen
millionen menschen sterben
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
leben nur noch ein paar hunderttausend
ureinwohner in den usa sie sind es die
in reservate wie pine ridge gesteckt
werden
[Musik]
die regeln machen auch hier die weißen
das indianische soll ausgemerzt werden
die sogenannten wilden gezwungen zu
leben wie alle anderen
bis in die 1970 er werden indigene
sprachen und religionen unterdrückt
kinder ihren eltern weggenommen und in
internate gezwungen junge frauen gar
zwangssterilisiert
[Musik]
die stolzen völker von einst sind nun
ein schatten ihrer selbst zu
bittstellern verkommen opfer der
geschichte bis heute verfolgt vom trauma
aus 500 jahren niedergang
wieder ein stück zurück mach dir keine
sorgen
halten die rede gerade
es war abgeschaltet wie waren im zweirad
modus wir können nicht reiten wir können
nicht fahren
was können wir überhaupt zumindest haben
wir jetzt an
[Gelächter]
heute steht der erste ausritt für uns an
da müssen wir jetzt beweisen dass wir
bereit sind für die red ants wenn ich du
wäre würde ich damit nicht reiten sogar
diese jungs die erfahrene reiter sind
schütteln die köpfe
ich schlage vor dass du nicht mit der
kamera ist ich fühle mich nicht so
schlecht wir bewegen uns auch noch nicht
ich nehme einfach diese kleine kamera
[Musik]
hierhin nicht zu tief da rein
nein nicht jetzt du musst deinen sitz
verbessern und drückt mir nach hinten
du solltest reitern wie auf einer welle
wenn du so hopp ist tut mir das weh und
du ruiniert dir deinen drücken
hinten gibt es auch rauf und runter ich
habe einfach ab so drücke mehr in die
steigt
sein zentrum sollte beim reiten
felsenfest sei ein wichtiger teil ist
auch durchaus keine panik aufkommen
lässt
versuche ganz bei dir zu bleiben es gibt
so viel zu beachten
man sollte also gar nie abheben
schau dir diese reiter sie sind wissen
sie gleiten buchstäblich dahin das
schwierigste auf dem pferd ist dieser
hoppe ligges schritt wenn du es auf die
nächste geschwindigkeit störte schaafs
ist alles wie sanft und es ist herrlich
falls du es dahin schafft
[Musik]
euro
ich bin sogar ein bisschen galoppiert es
war verrückt
es ist viel besser riecht haben ich bin
mir nicht sicher
und dann passiert mein pferd fox ab und
ich wir finden unser rhythmus
[Musik]
jetzt können die fans kommen der beste
rat den ich je hatte
du machst einen masterabschluss im
reiten was den zwei tagen gelernt was
normalerweise jahre abseits
ein pferd springt bewegt sich im galopp
folgt nicht nur der gruppe du hast viel
vertrauen in uns
oder aber wir sind ja einfach darauf
mich kümmert es ihr haltet euch wirklich
gut
die lakota sagen dass auch die pferde
nicht wollen dass ihre reiter und sie
versuchen sich um dich zu kümmern die
älteren sprechen manchmal davon wie sie
mit tieren sprechen konnten
das erste mal als ich das hörte dachte
ich ist schon gut spricht die ruhig mit
dem wild den business und den vögeln
jetzt denke ich dass es tatsächlich war
sie hatten dieser verbindung
meine ahnen und ich haben sie längst
verloren die hatten sie mal aber bei
irgendeiner ur ur ur großmutter kommt
dass frauen
ich glaube hier gibt es noch leute die
das kühl es scheint fast so als hätte
unsere zivilisation an einem umweg
gemacht und findet erst jetzt zurück zu
dem was wirklich wichtig ist
ich hoffe das stimmt ich hoffe wir
finden zurück
es ist so
[Musik]
wir brauchen zehn säcke eis also 205
reicht das für einen visionen das werden
wir herausfinden
der bison bestand im reservat wird vom
park rangers kontrolliert sie sagen
waren manche geschossen werden darf
wir sind hier mit den rangers und mit
everett verabredet der den bison erleben
will wie ist dein morgen
ich bin immer noch hier
ja ich hatte eine gute nacht
das everett überhaupt gekommen ist
überrascht uns ein wenig gestern ist
nämlich das passiert was häufig vorkommt
im reservat seine frau carol dean wäre
die halbe nacht lang unauffindbar
unterwegs um zu trinken schießt tauglich
sei er deshalb heute auf keinen fall
[Musik]
dave kennt solche situationen und er hat
darum seinen freund wayne gebeten
mitzukommen
ich bin bereit deshalb war ich in einem
bogen mitgebracht mit pfeil und bogen
ein tier töten das so viel wiegt wie ein
kleinwagen
die ranger sind skeptisch wie name ist
hier an
wenn das klappt wollen wir den bogen
sonst das gewehr
wir machen es wie immer ihr wollt
die gegend hier ist teil eines
nationalparks die bisons können sich
frei bewegen
schon riesen tiere
200.000 die satire gibt es heute wieder
in den usa vor 150 jahren waren es nur
wenige hundert
einst gab es mehr als 30 millionen
amerikanischer bisons teils wurden sie
dann jedoch gezielt ausgerottet und den
ureinwohnern die lebensgrundlage zu
nehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nun hoffen viele lakota das bisons
wieder teil ihres alltags werden teil
der seele des reservats was macht ihr
sonst noch mit einem wesen aus fleisch
zu essen
wir benutzen die knochen das fällen den
schädel einfach alles das ganze tier aus
dem hörnern keinen geschirr machen
es ist ein grund warum der vision so
wichtig ist für die lakota weil man
alles verarbeiten kann
ja das ganze tier
wlan macht sich bereit
er hat nur einen versuch mit seinem
bogen danach wollen die ranger vorwärts
machen und das gewehr auspacken
du kannst du sie noch sehen
nach kein schuss er sollte seine jacke
ausziehen
er muss bereit sein er ist nicht
überzeugt von sich ich habe das gefühl
das früher oder später pakistan
das wusste ich von anfang an
er hat ihn wirklich mit dem bogen
er hat ihn an der seite erwischt direkt
hier ist das gut oder schlecht
hier mitten ins herz
du hast nur einen schuss gebraucht das
ist das herz das ist das herz und hier
hat der pfeil getroffen ging also direkt
durch das ist der preis den bison
getötet ja der dem bison getötet dieser
eine vision liefert über 200 kilo
fleisch wir wollen erhöht und ihre
familien
das bedeutet uns viel wie lange wir das
reich wie für sie und ihre familie ein
leben lang
[Musik]
ein schuss ein pfeil ein treffer
unglaublich das grenzt an ein wunder
da sind sich alle einig es ist das erste
mal im leben das ich mit dem bogen
dass du gleich mit dem ersten schuss
trifft
so musste er nicht lange der wind hat
eine große rolle gespielt
eigentlich wäre der zahl so weit vorbei
gegangen ein pfeil vom wind geleitet
[Musik]
wundert nie hier sind wir an dem ort der
mehr als jeder andere für das leid der
lakota steht leon verpflegt diese
gedenkstätte die viel kleiner ist als
ich dachte es ist wirklich erstaunlich
dass bedenkt man die schwere dessen was
hier vorgefallen ist
dann würde man ein viel größeres denken
erwarten als zu bescheiden hier
vielleicht will amerika nicht erzählen
was es getan hat wenn man so viele
menschen töten muss um ihnen ihr land zu
nehmen und die aussage gemacht wir
werden auch den rest von euch töten wenn
ihr weiter kämpft so war die aussage
dann bin ich mir sicher dass sie hier
gar nicht hinstellen höchstens etwas das
sie selber kontrollieren
eure eigene geschichte erzählen
wir wollen das recht ist aus unserer
sicht zu erzielen
gemäß unserer mündlichen überlieferung
anstatt einer militärischen darstellung
welche die wirklich blutigen
geschehnisse aus lässt es geschah im
dezember 1890 zwei wochen nach dem tod
von häuptling sitting bull
soldaten der siebten kavallerie verüben
bei 100 nie eines der grausamsten
massaker in der geschichte der usa im
tumult der bei der entwaffnung von
gefangenen entsteht sterben zwischen 150
und 300 lakota darunter frauen und
kinder niedergemäht von soldaten die in
blinder panik feuern
weil der massenmord zunächst als
schlacht gilt erhalten 20 männer gar
tapferkeitsmedaillen bis heute wurden
diese nicht aberkannt
obwohl sich der kongress offiziell
entschuldigt hat wundert nie war das
traurige letzte kapitel der indianer
kriege und man ließ darüber nicht viel
in den geschichtsbüchern
nein tut man nicht haben sie vorher
schon darum als wir in der schule waren
stand ist noch in den büchern
jetzt nicht mehr warum
in den meisten schulen wird
amerikanische geschichte nicht mehr
unterrichtet wirklich nicht viel
mir scheint dies hier etwas zu sein was
es wert wäre dass man sich daran
erinnert
absolut wir wollten dass unsere enkel
davon hören sie tun das richtige
rund 80 jahre nach dem massaker stammt
dieser ort erneut im mittelpunkt eines
konfliktes
endlich wie die schwarze bevölkerung mit
der black power bewegung fanden auch
viele ureinwohner damals ein neues
selbstbewusstsein im american indian
movement 1973 besetzten aktivisten die
siedlung wundert bei zusammenstößen mit
der polizei kamen zwei von ihnen ums
leben
[Musik]
der stolz der lakota aber war zurück
heute leben knapp drei millionen
ureinwohner in den usa bei weitem nicht
alle in reservaten wie pine ridge doch
es sind diese gemeinschaften in denen
trotz aller armut der reichtum der
indianischen kultur auf lebt und den
menschen kraft gibt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist der tag des sieges vor 150 jahren
besiegte unser volk die us-regierung in
der schlacht um risiken auch bekannt
unter dem namen little bighorn in einer
legendären schlacht besiegten die lakota
angeführt vom sitting bull und crazy
horse die us armee unter general custer
der größte sieg der ureinwohner er wird
bis heute gefeiert natürlich mit pferden
und mit den besten reitern des stammes
auch nutzer gehört dazu der sohn von
leona die uns die gedenkstätte gezeigt
hat
[Applaus]
er hatte die idee dazu die idee ist
ziemlich alt älter als ich es gibt viele
wettkämpfe von denen gehört das
titelrennen ist nur zum spaß
das feld ziehen hingegen bedeutet dass
man jemandem und seine haut retten wenn
ein krieger in der schlacht verwundert
wird draußen auf dem feld liegen bleibt
dann muss man ihn da rausholen
man sieht ihn auf dem feld heraus das
nicht so
[Musik]
lukas bereit loszulegen
macht eure kriegs profis bereit
[Musik]
hier ist was los was los
cooper tritt auch in der härtesten
disziplin an eine meile ohne sattel wie
die alten krieger zweimal wurde er
bereits zweiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich hab's versucht locker und zweiter
platz das ist toll machst du zufrieden
mit dem zweiten platz und wie hast du
das feiern heute daheim in meinen
freunden das ist ein familien feiertag
ich will mich auch etwas erholen
[Musik]
wir haben
das will uns eigentlich nicht
was machst du uns sagen da oben werden
die zweite platz hinter der bretterwand
genau und dann gleich hier dass hier das
feuer sich zwischen den rauch unsere
kamera müssen wir nur dann abstellen
wenn den lakota etwas heilig ist zum
beispiel dass in die schwitzhütte sie
dürfen wir nicht zeigen teilnehmen aber
dürfen bei an der zeremonie navi hat uns
eingeladen
heute bin ich ein ältester ich bin 65
entdeckte diesen weg mit 40 das reservat
leben war wirklich schlecht
ich habe alles durchgemacht und war
wirklich am boden wie man so schön sagt
das hier hat mich dann gerettet
diese gebete diese art zu leben wenn sie
sagen mit akoya bedeutet dass wir sind
alle verwandt der kreis schließt wenn du
für menschen aufrichtig beet ist und
ihnen hilft dann wird dir der mann da
oben für deine hilfe etwas zurückgeben
in jeder schweiz hütte wird für etwas
bestimmtes gebiet zuerst bist du dafür
danach für dich selbst
du gehst da rein und reinigt seinen
körper und deinen geist sobald sich
diese türe wieder öffnet beginnst du ein
komplett neues licht
die schwitzhütte ist eigentlich ein
schweiz zählt hier versteckt hinter
einer bretterwand was dort gesagt wird
bleibt auch dort sagt man uns so soll
das sein
hier sei nur verraten es ist stockdunkel
gehören gesängen zu und beten gemeinsam
statt amen sagen wir mit der kroatin
wir sind alle 1
[Musik]
das feld der 16
die wärme da drin ist nicht nur
äußerlich sondern auch innerlich das ist
man selten heutzutage sei das moment der
stille wenn man gleichzeitig fallen kann
mit anderen man merkt einfach dass es
mehr gibt was die menschen verbindet
dass das was sie trennt
vielleicht werde man zufrieden über das
trennende zu wenig das verbindet also
sachen wir hier
wenn man dann einen moment teilt und
dinge teilt
hast du auch
[Musik]
dann ist er da der tag des großen
auftritts in die einzigartige natur der
bergland schroffe schönheit die einem
den atem raubt und darf sich noch retten
können
dafür holen wir aber noch teurer und
ihren freund hawks ab sie wird für uns
kochen
[Musik]
ich bin ich bin euch zu treffen wie geht
es dir schmelzen hier fast
entschuldigung haben wir euch warten
lassen ja schon ein bisschen aber das
ist in ordnung es ist mühsam zu können
ihr habt ein schweizer und das ist ein
galadiner oder
joana ist 19 jahre alt arbeitslos und
dennoch voller tatendrang
sie setzt sich in daves hilfswerk ein
für jugendliche in paris ich gründete
ein anti selbstmordprogramm als ich 14
war
was hast du selbst gegründet ja es heißt
das niemanden zurück im reservat gab es
vor einigen jahren nach dem selbstmord
ihm damals aber auch ich versucht mich
umzubringen
ich bin einer der glücklichen die
überlegt und ihr leben geändert haben
du hast versucht sich umzubringen ich
glaube jeder hat einen grund auf dieser
erde zu sein
viele einheimische jugendliche denken
sie haben keinen grund weil es hier
nichts für uns gibt
das wollte ich mich sowieso fragen was
tun junge menschen hauptsächlich
basketball football und leichtathletik
sport ist eine chance das reservat zu
verlassen
[Musik]
die erste vergewaltigung mit zwölf drei
fehlgeburten alkohol drogen thriller
sagt sie hätte ihr leben schon gelebt
ihre freunde nennen sie darum oma
aufgewachsen ist sie in einer familie
von alkoholikern in einem ort am rand
des reservats
[Musik]
wembley ist bekannt als the start of
stock ja weil so viele crystal meth
dealer dort sind und leute die vom
wetter abhängig sind
es ist verrückt es gibt 12 jährige die
mit ihren pfeifen in der hosentasche
einem feuerzeug und einem kleinen team
nach herum rennen hast du aufgenommen
ja ich war 14
fast über ein jahr war ich schwer
abhängig ein zwar nur weil ich dann
seien leute ich war neulich wollte
sängerin werden und mein vater sagte mir
niemand will ein fettes mädchen mit
pickeln und schrägen szenen als poster
an der wand
ganz zu stehen soll ich mache nur noch
auf mit den steigbügeln oder passt es so
du musst stehen können ich glaub ich
versuche es so ich habe ein ganz gutes
gefühl
ich setze mich einfach drauf breite
hierhin und dorthin und sage meinem
pferd hey baby der chef ist zurück und
ich glaube darauf reagiert sie sehen ja
das wird eine erste herausforderung
es geht auf beiden seiten steil runter
wenn du es durch diese stelle schaffst
es gut verloren
[Musik]
die band namens wurden einst vom
gletscher ausgehöhlt sie erstrecken sich
über mehrere tausend quadratkilometer in
den vierzigerjahren beschlagnahmte die
us armee einen großen teil davon um ihr
bomben zu testen
über 120 familien verloren dabei erneut
irland kommt bitte alle einmal hier
zusammen
[Musik]
joel hat angeboten für uns zu singen ich
bin hier darf ihr sehr dankbar
[Musik]
herten
[Applaus]
der
ap
tina dico
day
[Musik]
den abstieg haben wir geschafft haben
unsere pferde geschafft aber filmen war
dabei und möglich ich bin fast
runtergefallen verdrahtet vor allem
wohin kaum war die kamera draußen geht
das pferd wirklich den hang hoch grabow
wirklich schlecht merken sie dass wir
jetzt mal beim trab immer diesen
rhythmus zu finden weil ich glaube man
muss wie so ein bisschen sorgen
[Musik]
gut so richtig eins sind workshops und
ich noch nicht aber ich fühle wir
könnten es werden
mensch und tier natur und zivilisation
hier draußen verschwimmen diese grenzen
es klappt nicht immer aber manchmal
schon
dann denke ich jetzt bin ich richtig gut
unterwegs und dann wechselt wieder eine
sekunde
wie bist du eigentlich um die welt
terrakotta gekommen da gibt es viele
gründe die kultur die menschen die
geschichte wird zum teil geht es mir
auch darum ein unrecht wiedergutzumachen
das heißt anstatt ins gewissen
wie hat sich das wort schuld ich muss ja
nicht wie draußen sein aber doch ich
habe ein schlechtes gewissen
ich glaube das sagen wir alle irgendwie
auch ich fühle mich schlecht deshalb ich
bin zwar kein amerikaner jeder und ist
europa die europäer kamen hierüber hat
es dich vereine dafür zu sein
tiefgreifend eine sache die mich
verändert hat ist wenn man zum beispiel
über diese bäche hier redet die
schlüssel für sie sind das venen von
mutter erde
seit ich die welt mit diesen augen
betrachtet denke ich mir oft gott was
machen kann
ich verstehe dass jetzt wirklich wir
können das hier nicht einfach
verschmutzen
das sind wähnen das ist ein bild
kreislauf zuerst hörte sich etwas
esoterisch an fast schon kitschig aber
je länger man darüber nachdenkt und auch
die wissenschaft bestätigt es ja die
lakota wussten zwar nichts über
kohlendioxid und sauerstoff
ich kann aber neben diesem baum leben
atmen was er beim ausatmen
das ist doch erstaunlich also wenn das
nicht beweist alles ist verbunden
[Musik]
das ist dann auch was bleibt nach dieser
aufwühlenden woche die lakota leben
völlig anders als wir in brutaler armut
und in spirituellen reichtum in
bescheidenheit und stiller würde doch
verbindet uns viel wir sind ein teil der
erde
wir sind alle 1
da ist noch etwas was mich die ganze
woche beschäftigt das gesagt deine
kinder sind bessere kinder wegen des
reservats ein teil davon ist denke ich
dass meine kinder nicht nur mit der
lakota kultur in kontakt gekommen sind
sondern auch mit einer indigenen weiß
sie wurden damit nicht nur konfrontiert
sondern regelrecht hinein gezogen
diese art von weisheit in die ich ihnen
niemals beibringen können ich könnte das
nicht
ich habe gleichzeitig ein teil davon ist
auch die sie stellen sich die gleichen
fragen wie ich weinen deswegen und ihr
vater kann ihnen keine antworten geben
das ist einfach so
[Musik]
präsentiert wurden türen noch ein flug
ausfällt
[Musik]